what made you I guess step away from
religion there's a hole like that boy
that is a [__] loaded question
some topics are hard to approach either
the subjects are inaccessible or people
are uncomfortable discussing them the
women grow cannabis using a strain of
marijuana that eliminates THC but still
contains CBD touted for its healing
properties so we found those subjects in
person rented a space in LA and invited
our audience and strangers to come and
ask them anything
hello I'm sister Sarah I used to be a
Franciscan sister but today I'm a weed
nun we're gonna take some questions
today see you in a minute hey sister my
name is Eric how are you I'm doing great
Eric this is the weirdest confessional
I've ever been in bless you my child
our Father Son Holy Spirit oh sweet we
can swear when was your first time
smoking in Catholic junior high I had a
sleepover and I was 13 and I remember
getting sick to my stomach because I'd
never smoked anything before
did your parents know that you were
smoking heavens no
are you kidding me my mom's Irish
Catholic I would have been crucified how
long did it take use become a Catholic
nun about six years six years yeah Wow I
don't have really a state of reference
for what it's like to be a nun love to
hear like a package answer you know I've
seen like Sister Act but I don't think
that's particularly accurate the life of
a sister or a nun is very regimented you
get up at a certain time you pray at a
certain time you eat at a certain time
so at what age did you join and what
were you like before you joined I love
it
all right I was 19 when I joined I just
loved to get into trouble somehow I was
always very curious if I had a nice
family for the most part very strict
upbringing and so by the time I got to
the point in my life where I was ready
to serve something bigger than myself it
prepared me for going on and being
available to the spirit available to God
were there any I guess red flags in the
Catholic Church as a nun that I don't
know popped out at you you know what kid
here's the deal
I'm a victim of abuse had a few bad
situations with some clergy and it
scared the Dickens out of me I saw as I
grew and as I took on more
responsibilities that the people that
were over me
they were flood humans as well they
weren't gods they were just men
I just decided at one point do I want to
serve a situation that I don't no longer
support so I had to look at myself and
think okay I've I've put in 13 years but
what's gonna happen in the next 13 what
am I gonna see what am I gonna hear what
am I gonna experience so I decided and
it was a step of faith because I had
nowhere else to go I decided to leave
you want to know how I left um yeah
actually I'll tell you it was a Sunday
it was June 24th and the night before I
just felt like I gotta get out of here
so at breakfast time I talked to our
spiritual director who was a priest and
I said father you need to be available
around 4 o'clock today and he said
sister why I said father believe me you
need to be available to me if 4 o'clock
this afternoon with your car so when the
sisters went to prayer I had out
everything already packed
so when they went in one door I went out
the back door and the father was waiting
for me in his car and I escaped I was so
afraid for my life with everything that
was going on around me I was just in a
panic mode I was like I gotta get out of
here gotta get out of here now I'm not
happy the way I got out but everything
serves a purpose so what is something
that when you left that you got to
experience for the first time good gravy
a bottle of beer and a cigarette
football game he's never allowed to
watch football I was like my first Super
Bowl I was doing backflips how long was
a transition from being a Catholic nun
to working in this weed nursery I had a
space of time I went back into the world
got myself and learning had a beautiful
massage practice and then came to know
cannabis is my friend and as my healing
and my restoration and then I started to
think now how can I combine cannabis
with a calling and then I found this
wonderful tape as this video that was on
YouTube it was sister Kate and the
Sisters of the valley and there they
were in full habit smoking a joint
laughing enjoying themselves so I found
the information contacted sister Kate
she got back to me 20:18 that's when I
came to the sisterhood it's been the
best two years of my life how did going
into cannabis affect your religion like
did you get backlash from the people
that you're friends with it really
didn't affect my journey as far as my
friends because a lot of them they went
their journey
I took my journey and so I just had to I
don't want to say burn bridges but I do
want to say that if you can't journey
and you can't understand it's very
difficult to be a friend so no I
definitely relate with that because I'm
actually an advocate for a CVD as well
cool so just telling my friends that
were into the church they really shunned
me personally as well in your own words
what would you say weed nun is a woman
who wants excellence who wants to bring
forth the knowledge of the intelligent
planet which is cannabis we are wounded
healers and we seek to bring solace and
joy and help to the people that we we
work with what's like the biggest
difference in being a weed nun and like
a traditional nun when I was a
traditional nun I couldn't think for
myself and as a weed nun I can the
difference is also in my joy level it's
like I'm so happy because of what I
found it's like we have a plant that can
heal you and nurture you and restore you
women in the church they don't always
have the opportunity to minister and the
way that they would like I have the
opportunity now I can share freely with
people and I don't have to be afraid I
am raised in a very like no drugs no
alcohol kind of household which yeah I
really like that and like personally I
do get a little afraid of stuff that
like I don't really know
I pray that someday you will have the
courage to try the plant that would be
awesome in a safe place at a time when
your most comfortable
thank you so we'd to shop-owners that's
how your operation works no no no what
yeah what's your model yes so we purse a
flower like that our business is done on
the Internet
oh we don't take our stuff into like
Walgreens or anything quite yet and the
car sativa totally indica why it's one
of the best things for relieving of pain
and for PTSD so sativa helps you to
focus
indica helps you to relax got it I have
some favorite Saints in mind sure if I
list them off can you tell me the ones
who probably maybe partook in cannabis
and maybe ones he probably didn't sure
word let's go with that let's go with
Mother Teresa
no she was not she was a teetotaler
we're enough or about st. Thomas More
Thomas More was a drinker so I'd say he
was a party boy yeah and last but not
least she was bold she was wild
Joan of Arc party girl yeah I'm sure do
you have any regrets in life like really
big ones you know what I don't have any
regrets what happened happened it's in
the past I've grown from things and I'm
walking a certain walk that brings me
much peace and joy so I would say yeah
and amen
I feel like that that's really cool that
you have something that you feel very
connected to well you appreciate that
thank you so very much thank you I'm
glad that you've made it through and
that you're happy and that you're moving
on and that you're doing your own thing
that's amazing thank you blessings on
you and your life I don't know what I
was expecting but it definitely wasn't
that I hope it was good it's definitely
an experience that will go in the book
well bless you my child I've enjoyed it
thank you so much for being here with us
today it's been my pleasure to share my
journey with you and please remember to
comment below you saw the video feel
free to subscribe like the video and
we'll see you next time and be lifted
you